not for me
not i'd rather sit pins in me that's
giving me flashbacks to the toilets at
glastonbury oh yeah
where you going in mexico
[Music]
my name's paddy considine and i'm matt
smith and this is uh uk versus usa snap
wars for lab bible
bush
yeah look at this eh
gotta inspect a clue so
[Music]
it's a good job you're not a criminal
[Laughter]
right here we go what is it
oh sweet stuff oh these are walls stuff
you know
is that that's the english one yeah
that's why i ordered too sweet and i
mean even that's melted
that's no good
[Laughter]
it's pure rubbish in it yeah but i'm
gonna go with there's no nutritional
value in it but i'm like you i'm going
for oreo yeah that's vital there's
better walls ice creams than that i'm
not sure what your favorite ice creams
what'd you go for i'm not a big ice
cream man i'm not either raspberry
[Laughter]
shirt i didn't realize it was going to
be so dirty
you recognize is that that looks [ __ ]
awful that
goober so this is what peanut butter
mixed in with um
jelly jelly sorry yeah not for me
not i'd rather sit pins in me that's
giving me flashbacks to the toilets that
glasses oh yeah
i like peanut butter and jelly but
that's kind of weird yeah yeah yeah
cheers
there's too much jelly in it
it's a weird consistency in it yeah
yeah not for me no not for me so this is
that's like this
do i recognize this marmite this is made
in my hometown of burton on trampoline
is it yeah is that where it's from yeah
yeah so not a problem i bet this all my
life
this is clearly the winner yeah yeah
good old blighty so how much would you
put on that because i definitely overdid
everything that's right for me that is
it loads it's like a twist
yeah yeah yeah basically that can do one
yeah so who wins i think we know
okay uk yeah uk wins my team here we are
colombo
should i do this one man yeah
i don't i can't eat that
that's a no for me brizzy hubba bubba
don't i don't do chewing gum up for this
that i mean that's one already for me
what has dib dab yeah
yeah i like them both this was around
when i was a kid horrible yeah
this is old school you can throw some
fantastic bubbles of this
can you oh yeah you need more than one
okay
this might take a bit of time
to eat that again
having a moment here
paddy we're gonna wait for some bubble
we're gonna try and
you can you've got mushroom around here
yeah yeah you're gonna make all right
mush very mush this is gonna be the
bubble industry in
this is it worst nightmare
it was like the oreo that it was like a
wet oreo
[Laughter]
how are we going to clear this up
i'm gonna i mean they're both really
great yeah you had dib dab didn't you oh
i did dad
when we have a drawer no one's gonna win
you can have drums yes i'm gonna go huh
withdrawal
that was good
this might be more
yeah
there we are here we are
the pig pants up
what's this
this is a mountain of pancakes
pasta yeah in cornwall yeah yeah
what's this
even though
that smell makes me like
under these circumstances sorry if if i
try and bite that i'll heave
i'm gonna go
just because i eat more
i think there's only one winner is there
yes this
i think there's stupid this yeah yeah
yeah usa wins usa the usa winning
try a little bit what was all this you
could
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah that wins usa wins
this is great though this is a big this
is a tradition
yeah all right and when they're done
properly not against us don't do them
properly because this has been related
microwave run it you've just banged this
in the microwave for five minutes
is that english yeah
the bounty hunters are here searching
for paradise
yeah a little bit of paradise they taste
like sick
[Laughter]
whereas this my friend
is the taste of paradise
[Music]
yeah fiber went up yeah bounty easily
bounty late it's not good
i'll just do it for the crowd but
i mean you know
in the commercial chocolate steaks it's
just
knowledge that the uk is bad yeah yeah
you know
what about this little one in this
country
oh yeah yeah yeah save all the delicious
coconut yeah
i do like that with a twix okay so
bouncy bouncy wins
it was a draw
it was a draw sometimes it happens
yeah you slam you win you lose you just
go reassess it and then move on yeah
don't dwell on it don't dwell on the
draw but god's sake
[Laughter]
it was a lot more fun than i thought
yeah
what oh yeah all dressed
this is exciting
i've been explaining these to margot
robbie
who loves snacks and doesn't doesn't
seem seems to be totally baffled by the
idea of an all an all-dressed chip but
it does exist
[Music]